chris flexon will be making his third
start on the year 1-0 record four and a
half era ten innings he has four walks
and eleven strikeouts
[Music]
towards the line marmo has got some room
their territory went out
hard right field line drives there
nicely
[Music]
bouncing ball shortstop jp crawford
great dig by evan white
back in seattle the bottom of the first
inning between the astros and mariners
and there you see right-hander zach
granky
chopper to the right side
moving to his left is oled miss diaz to
make the play
it's been about 50 50 as kyle seeger
sends one to left how about zach good
inning to start this one one two three a
couple of ground outs and a fly out to
end the first we go to the top of the
third and veteran catcher jason castro
will lead it off for houston that was on
the road 2-2
right three crawl first strikeout
in the ball game
right at the bottom of the zone
terrence framing it
now flexing looking for a ground ball
double play to get out of the inning no
score and here is a tough tough hitter
[Music]
and yuli guriel
bouncing balls may do it there's one
demo over the first dug out five in
white yes indeed double play get out of
trouble we go to the home third dylan
moore is gonna lead off
six up six down so far for grinky bottom
third for seattle no score
fastball sent in the air to right field
kyle tucker shades his eyes from the sun
and puts it away for out number one
that's a curveball and that's in between
both correa and diaz in the shift jp
crawford matches his career high with an
eight-game hitting streak
swing and a miss grenky picks up his
first strikeout
second out of the inning
pulled the string on him with the change
up and zach picks up back to back
strikeouts getting haggerty and hanniger
to end the third inning one hit one man
left on base scoreless through three top
of the fourth inning michael brantley
will lay things off he doubled back in
the first inning one-for-one
facing chris flexon second time around
and uncle mike has a base hit down the
left field line just staying fair past
kyle seeger
michael brantley is two for two and owns
two of the astros four hits
oh line jive eludes the diving second
baseman dylan moore and the astros will
have two on with one out so two on and
two outs no score top of the fourth and
here's designated hitter taylor jones a
kid born in kent washington taylor jones
with a clean single to center field will
drive in the game's first run
taylor jones with a base hit makes it
one to nothing in the jones squad over
from kent washington happy with that hit
base hit
as jones drives in a run astros take the
lead two out lightning
that was that cutter that's over the
outside corner and
that six seven frame gets those arms
extended and barrels up shoots it back
up the middle
nice piece of hitting and a big moment
for the astros
family loving it
one nothing astros late at bottom of the
fifth in seattle jose marmaleo stands in
all hit hard over the shift
and into right field marmalajos has a
leadoff single for the mariners here in
the fifth inning
nine the entire year
there's a ball in the left field for a
base hit
evan white has a single
marmalajo stops at second the mariners
have their best threat of the evening
first and second nobody out
so one out of two on for jp crawford who
singled through the shift in the third
line drive zach makes the catcher does
he he lets it drop what's the ruling
they're going to get the out at third
and a double play
zach thought he caught the line driving
came out of his glove he spun around and
he got a double play out of it
how about that for the six time gold
glove award winner one nothing astros
lead in seattle bottom of the sixth
there you go martine maldonado watching
zach greggy pick up another strikeout
that's now four strikeouts he makes
quick work out of hagerty a three pitch
k
there's curveball
no problem for carlos correa
he rips one caught by yuli diving
stopped by yuli taps the bag just in
case they needed a fourth out but julie
curiel catches the line drive to end the
sixth inning
and seattle will send four five six in
the order to face grinky
wow that's a wicked change of bottom
falling out of that one what a beautiful
pitch oh two changed to turins and he
picks up another strikeout five
strikeouts for zach one away
wagon
67 mile an hour curveballs that grencke
looking great tonight two outs into the
seventh
duo pitch hit hard but one hop to carlos
correa bounce throw in time to get white
and a one two three seventh inning for
zach cranky with a couple of strikeouts
in the mix we head to the eighth astros
and grenky leading one nothing best
tower
lead off man here in the eighth michael
brantley
strike three call
got a bench
so one on one away one nothing houston
top of the eighth and here's oled miss
diaz
strike three called
[Applause]
we've seen a number of sliders in the
inning but i think he goes back to his
change up
typically he'll throw the change up more
yep there it is the vulcan you can see
it turning sideways that shows with a
lot of hits not with a lot of runs and
grinky has been answering the bell every
time he's allowed four singles through
seven innings throws them the hook at
one and two and it's sent into shallow
center field miles straw comes in makes
the play for out number one
and that's lifted shallow left field
toward the line goes brantley squeezes
it and crawford is done on one pitch two
outs in the eighth here comes the o2 to
hagerty
ground ball head to the right side into
the shift to his right diaz he fields
throws to first and the inning is over
eight shutout innings for zach ranky
bottom of the ninth inning ryan presley
will face the top of the order trying to
hold on to a one-nothing game that zach
cranky was brilliant at 02 on the ground
gloved by yuli guri allen the astros are
going to snap the losing streak it ends
with a one-nothing brilliantly pitched
game by zach grenke and ryan presley the
astros winners tonight they needed zach
cranky he is at the top of that rotation
leading the way he understood the
situation and another great outing for
him on the road